le gouverneur républicain de l'État de
la Floride promet que ce n'est pas
terminé
ce fardeau il ne devrait pas tomber
uniquement sur le dos des états
républicains une cinquantaine de
migrants vénézuéliens ont été envoyés
sur l'île cossu de Martin Vigneux un
bastion démocrate prisé par l’élite
politique américaines le gouverneur des
sentiers ça lui-même a fêter les vols à
partir du Texas
pour traverser le Mexique enfin nous
sommes rendus explique ce venezuelien
d'origine après avoir été accueilli par
des travailleurs communautaires les
autorités ont annoncé que les migrants
sont finalement transférés sur une base
militaire depuis des mois des ténors
républicains comme le gouverneur du
Texas font transporter des migrants dans
des états démocrates pour dénoncer les
politiques migratoires de Joe Biden
la tension manquerait d'un cran dans les
derniers jours quand d'autres réfugiés
ont été envoyés tout près de la
résidence de la vice-présidente Camara
Harris
je pense que c'est vraiment le bordel
c'est vraiment horrible la façon dont
ils utilisent des gens comme des pions
il y avait plus de journalistes à Martin
Vigneux qu'il y en a jamais eu au sud de
la frontière vous devriez vous y rendre
afin de constater ce qui se passe
la Maison Blanche dénonce ce qu'elle
qualifie de mise en scène alors que les
républicains espèrent que la question
soit un des thèmes centraux lors de
l'élection de mi-mandat ici Mélissa
François Radio-Canada Montréal